(rock music)
- [Host] When Mad Max meets Burning Man
you get Wasteland Weekend.
Wasteland Weekend takes place
in the middle of
California's Mojave Desert
and is the world's largest
post-apocalyptic festival.
Founded in 2010, this four day event
sees nearly 3,000 desolation enthusiasts.
Attendees are required to dress
in the post-apocalyptic style dress code
and the costumes don't disappoint.
Festival organizers design
and build elaborate set pieces
but it's the gear heads who attend
that bring the world of
crumbling civilization to life.
So as long as you're willing to commit
to the spirit of the end of the world,
you'll be welcomed with open arms.
(rock music)